>> Laura: THE NRA BOYCOTT HAS
MUSHROOMED MORE THAN A DOZEN
MAJOR CORPORATIONS CUTTING TIES
WITH THE SECOND AMENDMENT GROUP,
AND THEY INCLUDE DELTA AND
UNITED AIRLINES.
MEANWHILE, PRESIDENT TRUMP
CRITICIZED THE FIRST RESPONDERS
AT THE PARKLAND FLORIDA
HIGH SCHOOL SHOOTING AFTER
REPORTS SURFACED THAT AS MANY AS
FOUR DEPUTIES TOOK COVER INSTEAD
OF PURSUING THE SHOOTERS.
-- THE SHOOTER.
>> THAT WE PERFORMED WAS,
FRANKLY, DISGUSTING.
THEY WERE LISTENING TO WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
YOU DON'T KNOW UNTIL YOU'RE
TESTED, BUT I REALLY BELIEVE I
WOULD RUN IN THERE EVEN IF I
DIDN'T HAVE A WEAPON.
I THINK MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM WOULD HAVE DONE THAT
TOO.
BUT THE WAY THEY PERFORMED WAS
REALLY A DISGRACE.
>> Laura: JOINING US NOW TO
REACT TO THE LATEST ON THE
SHOOTING AS WHITE HOUSE DEPUTY
PRESS SECRETARY HOGAN GIDLEY.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU IN TONIGHT.
YOU HAD A LONG DAY TODAY,
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GET INTO
THE PRESIDENT'S REACTION.
I WANTED REACTION TO WHAT WE
UNCOVERED TONIGHT ABOUT THE
SHERIFF ISRAEL, WHO -- QUITE A
PIECE OF WORK.
NOW WE FIND OUT THAT THEY ARE
SENDING OVER THESE SYSTEM-WIDE
EMAIL SAYING, SUPPORT THE
SHERIFF, SUPPORT THE SHERIFF.
KIND OF A CYA MODE.
>> THE POINT IS TO FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPEN.
FOR HIM TO FUSE THIS TIME TO GO
OUT ON THIS POLITICAL TOUR TO
TRY TO BOLSTER HIS OWN POLITICAL
AGENDA, A GUN GRAB, WHICH IS SO
FASCINATING.
DEMOCRATS IN THESE TIMES, AS
THEY KNOW, GO IMMEDIATELY TO
ENDING THE SECOND AMENDMENT, AND
THAT THE GOVERNMENT PROTECT YOU.
WE HAVE SEEN WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
DID AT THE FBI, WITH SOME OF THE
DATE OF THE LOCAL LEVEL, AND NOW
IT'S IN THE DEPUTIES OUTSIDE WHO
WERE TRAINED AND HAD GUNS AND
DIDN'T GO IN.
I HAD TO PROTECT MYSELF WITH MY
OWN GUN OR THAT THE GOVERNMENT
DO IT, I'LL TAKE MYSELF EVERY
DAY OF THE WEEK.
>> Laura: IT'S VERY ODD THAT
THE AUTHORITIES SAW ISIS FLAGGED
IN ONE OF THE VISITS, LIKE,
OBSESSED WITH "FINAL EXAM."
I
WOULD THINK THAT A KID THAT WAS
A MEXICAN THESE WEAPONS,
OBSESSED WITH ISIS, TALKED ABOUT
A SCHOOL SHOOTING, THAT IS KIND
OF AN EASY ONE.
HE PROBABLY DON'T GET ALL OF
THESE FACTORS TOGETHER -- AND HE
TORTURED ANIMALS.
>> IT IS SO SAD WHAT WAS MISSED
HERE, >> AN INCREDIBLE MEETING,
GRIEVING PARENTS, GRIEVING
CHILDREN, STUDENTS FROM AROUND
THE AREA WHO WERE SO JUST ANGRY
AND FRUSTRATED AND FURIOUS, AND
ALSO SO SAD AT WHAT HAPPENED,
AND NOW WE KNOW SO MUCH OF THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED HAD
ANY OF THESE ONE FLAGS BEEN
TAKEN THROUGH THE PROPER
CHANNELS, THIS COULD HAVE ALL
BEEN STOPPED.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES IT SO
EGREGIOUS.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT MY
OBJECTION THAT THE PRESIDENT
ASKED SESSIONS TO INVESTIGATE
THIS?
>> THAT IS AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
>> Laura: HAVING THEM
INVESTIGATE THIS, AS RICK SCOTT
SAID, THEY'RE GOING TO DO THIS.
>> I HAVEN'T SPOKEN TO HIM ABOUT
THAT, BUT THE DOJ OBVIOUSLY HAS
A ROLE HERE IF IT SO CHOOSES.
>> Laura: THE MEDIA, THEY ARE
OBSESSED WITH THE REPUBLICAN
PLURALIST RELATIONSHIP WITH THE-
THE REPUBLICANS RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE NRA.
>> THIS REMINDS ME SO MUCH --
THIS IS A MORE GRIEVOUS ISSUE.
REMEMBER WHEN EVERYONE CAME OUT
AGAINST THE DIXIE CHICKS, KIND
OF THE BLOW BACK WITH THEY SAID
ABOUT PRESIDENT BUSH.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF THING THAT
IS RIDICULOUS FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF, WE HAVE A
SECOND AMENDMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT SUPPORTS THAT
AMENDMENT, SUPPORTS THE NRA.
THE NRA SUPPORTS THIS PRESIDENT.
CORPORATIONS CAN DO WHAT THEY
WANT TO.
BUT TO COUNT HOW TO PRESSURE
LIKE THIS ON SOMETHING THAT IS
WRITTEN IN OUR CONSTITUTION
IS ABSOLUTELY --
>> Laura: THE PARIS AND IS IN
FAVOR OF
SOME RESTRICTIONS, GET RID OF
THE PUMP STOCK FOR SURE, THAT IS
OBVIOUS, PERHAPS STILL RAISING
THE AGE FOR PURCHASE, FIRST-TIME
PURCHASE OF A SEMI AUTO RAFFLE?
>> WE HAVE A MEETING TODAY, IT
IS INTERESTING TO BRING THIS UP.
OVER THEN THE FAMILIES WE TALKED
ABOUT, AND THE STUDENTS ARE
DISTRAUGHT, WE ALSO MET WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
THEN REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS,
DOZENS OF THEM --
>> Laura: WHAT IS THE
CONSENSUS?
THEY WANT A BAN ON ASSAULT
WEAPONS?
>> THEY DIDN'T BRING UP THE AGE
RAISING ONE TIME.
AGAIN, THE PRESIDENT IS
LISTENING, AND WHEN YOU SIT WITH
THE GOVERNORS OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL, TRY TO HELP STOP THESE
SHOOTINGS, WHEN THEY DON'T BRING
THAT UP, THAT IS TELLING.
>> Laura: IF YOU GO TO WAR AT
18 AND YOU VOTE AT 18, YOU CAN
BUY MAKE A RIFLE AT 18.
I GUESS.
I'M NOT EVEN MAKING A COMMENT.
WE LET PEOPLE DO A LOT AT 18.
MAYBE WE SHOULD RAISE THE AGE OF
EVERYTHING.
WHAT ABOUT THE DACA DECISION?
DECIDING NOT TO COME UP FOR NOW,
TAKE THAT.
>> ON THE FACE, THE SIMPLICITY,
I THINK YOUR VIEWERS CAN
UNDERSTAND THIS.
THEY SAY THAT BARACK OBAMA WAS
WELL WITHIN HIS RIGHTS, IT
WASN'T UNCONSTITUTIONAL, IT
WASN'T UNLAWFUL.
HE HAS THE POWER AS PRESIDENT TO
ESTABLISH DACA AND STOP DACA.
IF HE HAS THE POWER TO START
DACA, BUT DOESN'T THIS PRESIDENT
HAVE THE POWER TO STOP DACA?
IT WOULD MAKE SENSE IF IT IT IS
A PRESIDENTIAL POWER.
THE PROBLEM IS, IT'S NOT, IT'S A
MOUTHFUL.
WE ARE UPSET.
THIS HAS TO BE SOLVED ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER.
>> Laura: THE COURT DOESN'T
USUALLY LIKE THAT.
YOU CAN GO BACK TO THE
NINTH CIRCUIT, THEN GO BACK TO
THE SUPREME COURT, THEY MIGHT
ACCEPT THE CASE AT THAT POINT.
>> Laura: NEW MEXICO GOING TO